hello and welcome to see are playing nut
roast and not roast not host 2015 okay
we'll see okie dokie a c5 that's not a
particularly great line white can
capture and then don't really know it
okay I'm still taking up that challenge
c4 is leading to the maroc see probably
which is one of my favorite lines this
is why I'm hesitating but okay he takes
you five is supposed to be excellent for
white so I'm giving it giving it a go
okay not a 6mm
yeah taking it with said an idea I don't
know looks a little bit no but it's very
quickly I'm developing very quickly if I
take it's also worse worth something
very quick development so hmm what to do
now rookie one and yes from p1 I guess
he has tough time with this night then I
have six and pushing g5 not so easy to
develop this
yeah he ultimately decided to try to
develop it I think I go in five now
using the time gainer him wow that is
playable can hardly believe it
and the reason why I'm skeptic is that
that night has no squares I mean no
squares after something like Queen to
deform he probably will play I don't
know what he will play have five that
looks pretty awful but maybe he has to
okay so Quincy for I guess still
attacking the night that still has no
squares and preventing black from
castling okay you know checking is one
option or just taking of course after
the check has 27 itself seems kind of
okay now we are check on it for or
somewhere else queen queen is six outs
animals queen is six bishop f3 Queen f6
but drew gave aid still looks pretty
awful hmm I don't know yeah let show me
not bad
and behind on time quite a bit have to
be cautious they're not the fault too
much behind I have a given no taking
this uh-huh so green f6 is Queenie one
okay so what is the point after Bishop
d2 Queen a fire
or just 93 yeah why not why not why not
develop that these 6 + f6 are hanging
and Bishop the two is not a very helpful
move anyway and I don't see you for
black they are both hanging f6 and d6
are you can remove the king but that is
kind of last resort him a king evade
this Bishop age 60 king da de yeah
that's made in one checkmate but yeah
anyway that was a that was just an
unplayable opening in that way um yeah I
mean that whole line will see 5 is
pretty questionable the mainline whoever
goes some Queen 85 check n c3 Quincy
five and now night to a 3 this is
supposed to be them um the the problem
for for black and he indeed has a hard
time i think i'm not mistaken the best
line now is a night to have six after
which sorry Knight f6 after which white
has some options this is a simple one
that leads to an advantage but I think
there are even better continuations but
i'm not a huge expert um yeah this is
however what normally is done okay here
i am i just went for the form fatiguing
for speeding up development he captured
and cancelled yeah and I'm just much
better developed and the pawn on c5 is
still not I mean black has not regained
at him he's down one porn for his
miserable position
okay this is my deaf six looks very
normal and yeah 24 I don't know this has
no squares it just loses I think yeah
this is given by the comp but Bishop age
six is pretty powerful it's a nice month
and something something like this is an
extra porn and huge pressure for white
or alternatively and we take subs cheeks
here it's also far far away from being
being ideal them okay took with that and
interestingly enough the engine wants to
go Queen to b4 yeah that is actually a
very good idea it's a double attack
essentially takes with the rook and
queen takes b7 is the threat now that
wins more material Ian this is also not
so bad but Queen before is better i
infected is bad the computer gives rook
c8 with a good position for black wow
why ah wow that's a cool trick no I
didn't see that at all yeah this is a
very cool trick I cannot take here
because of d5 that's very very very very
nice yeah and the capture is impossible
the rukon see aid I can check here but
Bishop c6 that's pretty remarkable
wow so Quincy for was a big mistake
actually my I didn't see the t5 resource
absolutely not hey this is the only
thing that he can play also did
everything else is losing basically he
has a move that is good and and stuff
that losers like like here this is a
plus plus 4 position he cannot say this
his pieces him don't hear this one was
made straight away so hmm that was still
amazing that Queen to c4 is a mistake
here I mean it is also once you see
Queen before it's pretty clear that this
is good but I was thinking Quincy force
is doing almost the same thing the night
still has no squares and they only move
that I saw what d5 I didn't think on
quickly like rook c8 and then that this
is a that's really really amazing um the
question is do we have something better
I mean this is given by the computer and
it's not now I mean this is a position
but I'm not better here huh remarkable
yeah I Roxy eight what's water resource
okay very interesting okay thanks for
watching